the second of mcu's disney plus series
after one division wraps up will be the
falcon and the winter soldier which will
bring steve rogers two well-loved
sidekicks into their very own spotlight
here's everything we know about the
falcon and the winter soldier
while the falcon in the winter soldier
was originally announced alongside the
rest of marvel's phase four offerings
with a vague release date to fall 2020.
the series has since been rescheduled
for a release date of march 19
2021 this makes it the second of
marvel's new disney plus series
premiering just a couple of weeks after
the final episode of wand wandavision is
set to drop
anthony mackey will of course be
reprising his role as sam wilson the
falcon
though steve rogers bequeath sam his
shield at the end of end game it isn't
clear yet just how or when he will be
adopting the mantle of captain america
in an interview with mtv news in 2019
mackie gave a tantalizing teaser
i don't know what day it will be you
will wear that captain america costume
i just had my first fitting no you
didn't i did tell me
it looks really good sebastian stan will
also be reprising his role as bucky
barnes aka the winter soldier
after some time spent quite literally
chilling with king t'challa
followed by a blip to the afterlife and
back we have a new and frankly untested
bucky to meet
what the falcon lacks in super powered
brawn bucky more than makes up for with
his fresh wakandan made prosthetic arm
curiously both mackie and stan took
turns holding the iconic shield at the
sdcc panel announcing their show and its
release date
is it a tease of things to come both sam
and bucky are well known for having worn
the mantle of captain america on the
comics page at one point or another
could the tv show follow suit daniel
bruhl will be reprising his role as the
cunning helmet zemo last seen in captain
america civil war
at the moment we don't know if zemo was
blipped per the term introduced in
spider-man far from home but he has a
new look
long time fans may know that original
flavor comics zemo had a bag
accidentally glued to his head
we doubt his screen costume will have
origins quite so silly but the trailer
shows emo carrying a surprisingly comics
accurate hood
bucky in particular will have a bone or
two to pick with him after the events of
captain america civil war
will he be safe now from the special
trigger word zemo used on him before
and what has he been up to in the
interim lip or no blip when we last left
him king t'challa had stayed zemo's
suicidal hand
ensuring he would stay alive and
imprisoned for his multiple crimes
not the least of which was the killing
of king t'chaka
a bigger surprise in the return of our
two heroes and their nemesis is the
revelation that emily van kamp is
reprising her role as sharon carter aka
agent 13 in the show though how integral
her role will be is unknown
sharon didn't feature an infinity war or
end game at all and van camp currently
stars in the medical drama the resident
on fox
nonetheless her character's inclusion in
the cast is interesting
we don't know whether sharon was
affected by the blip or how she's been
coping since then five years hence
with sharon no longer in the cia after
providing steve rogers with classified
information in civil war
we're filled with questions about what
she's been up to since siding with
captain america over her former
employers
even if the whole world is telling you
to move
it is your duty to plant yourself like a
tree
look them in the eye and say no disney's
big d23 expo in august 2019
dropped some tantalizing news for the
falcon in the winter soldier wyatt
russell will be playing john walker aka
us agent walker is in simplest terms a
kind of politically opposite captain
america
often functioning as an anti-hero
antagonist rather than an outright
villain
his costume even looks very similar to
caps in the comics he exists to
discredit cap and works as an avatar of
the us government
falling in line where steve rogers
famously refused to comply
walker's presence suggests that sam and
bucky could have a fight on their hands
of protecting steve's vision for
superheroes
and may wind up having to defend the
very idea of what it means to be captain
america
in early 2021 don sheedle told bro
bible's post-credit podcast that james
roadie rhodes aka war machine will also
be making an appearance in the falcon in
the winter soldier
rhodey has technically been around from
the very beginning of the mcu
although during his first appearance in
iron man he was played by terence howard
cheeto came aboard the franchise in iron
man 2 taking over for howard and has
been tony stark's right-hand man in the
mcu ever since
now with tony gone it appears as though
roadie will finally be stepping into the
spotlight as the star of the upcoming
mcu disney plus series armor wars
which will see roadie dealing with the
threat arising from some of stark's tech
falling into the wrong hands
for now we don't know if his appearance
in the falcon and the winter soldier
will help set the stage for armor wars
or if roadie will be showing up solely
to help out his fellow avengers and
whatever problems they face
kerry skoglund will be directing all six
episodes of the falcon in the winter
soldier
she is most lauded for her work on the
handmaid's tale earning an emmy
nomination and winning a baptist for the
hulu series
many of her other directorial credits
are either tense political thrillers or
dark genre fair with episodes of the
borges boardwalk empire and the walking
dead under her belt
if her apparent specialized skill set is
going to be exercised that would be
something of a tone change for the mcu
the show's composer henry jackman has
described it as a psychological drama
saying there's very much serious issues
now more than ever about what it means
to hold cap's shield and what kind of
person should ultimately be holding that
shield and with the history of this
country and how african americans would
feel about being
captain america or not it's a great
balance of entertainment and writing
centering around more weighty issues
it would seem that skoglyn's track
record of balancing similarly weighty
issues with taught storytelling and
thrilling action makes her the perfect
fit for the marvel series
the first chief screenwriter attached to
the falcon and the winter soldier back
in 2018 was malcolm spellman
previously most recognizable for his
work on fox's music industry familial
drama empire
early in 2019 the project also landed
derek colstad
original creator of the character john
wick and co-writer of the genre changing
series of glitzy high octane action
films
it's unknown that these two writers will
be working collaboratively across all
episodes or if their efforts will be
designated to individual installments
according to series star sebastian stan
what the show's writing team has come up
with feels cinematic in its tone
stan told the hollywood reporter what i
loved about the show was that tonally it
was very much in the same world that
captain america the winter soldier was
so in a sense it was grounded and very
much in the world as we know it
but it's also really jam-packed with a
lot of massive massive action scenes
mixed with deep focus on character
we can put them in situations that we've
never been able to put them in before
because you now have six hours as
opposed to two
in addition to the return of emily van
camp daniel bruhl and dan sheedel
the falcon and the winter soldier will
also be bringing back another familiar
face with georges san pierre reprising
his role as george batrock
aka batroc the leaper the same character
he played in captain america the winter
soldier
sampier's role in the winter soldier was
small but memorable with a character
engaging in an impressive martial arts
heavy one-on-one fight with the captain
himself
as far as new characters go in addition
to the introduction of wyatt russell's
john walker the cast will include a
number of fresh faces
including aaron kellyman carl lumbley
and many more
it's clear from the trailer that
kellyman will be playing one of the flag
smashers
although it's possible her role may be
more complex but details on any other
roles have been scarce
some have speculated that alias alumnus
lumbly may be playing isaiah bradley
aka the black captain america not only
would including bradley fit with the
historical and racial themes that
composer henry jackman promised would be
present in the show
but the character is also the
grandfather of young avengers member
elijah bradley aka patriot
with wandavision introducing billy aka
wicken and tommy aka speed
hawkeye bringing on kate bishop ant-man
and the wasp quantomania including a
teenage cassie lang
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness introducing teen hero america
chavez we can't help but notice that the
mcu seems to be laying the groundwork
for an eventual young avengers team
including isaiah bradley and the falcon
in the winter soldier seems like a
natural early step toward that goal
a reported rumors suggests an
overarching plot line in the series will
be that the us government doesn't
approve of sam becoming captain america
even after steve rogers was instrumental
in reversing the blip and defeating
thanos it would seem that captain
america is still persona non grata to
the united states government
as he was following the events of
captain america civil war
adding composer henry jackman's comments
about how the racist history of the
united states will weigh into the public
perception of a black man as captain
america
and the presence of wyatt russell's u.s
agent and it's safe to say that sam's
path toward acceptance in his new role
won't be an easy one
additionally bucky is still considered
an enemy of the state he may have joined
in the final battle against thanos
forces at the avengers compound but the
world at large wasn't there to witness
it
manipulation of public opinion is a
growing theme in the mcu and has always
been a problem for bucky during his
journey towards recovery
teemo was after all the original
architect of the fake news about bucky's
dangerous ways in civil war and he's
backed as a full-blown
villain in the falcon and the winter
soldier all of this seems to add up to
bucky and sam not necessarily being
welcomed back into a post-blip
world with open arms to celebrate the
start of filming of the falcon and the
winter soldier back in 2019
anthony mackie and sebastian stan did
what several of their mcu co-stars have
done in the past
they took over the official marvel
studios instagram account and posted
about the first day of filming
the series of small clips on the
account's story featured some light
banter between the 2x sidekicks as they
stepped into their new leading roles
along with that we were treated to
concept art of the duo's new getups when
disney plus went online in november
2019.
launch day for the streamer included a
short documentary entitled marvel
studios expanding the universe which
gave a short rundown of what we can
expect from all the mcu mini-series
coming to the streaming service in the
next few years
once marvel dropped their extended first
look at the series in late 2020 followed
by the full trailer in early 2021
those drawings came to life before our
eyes giving us our first live-action
glimpses of sam's patriotic new wings
bucky's tough new all-black ensemble
redesigned looks for sharon carter and
zemo
and a fleeting look at the back of john
walker's u.s agent uniform
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one